hey 42 here this hateful son of a birch
is a deadliest tree in the world the
Spanish call it Manzanilla dellamorta
meaning little apple of death its
scientific name is HIPAA may my Selah
which translates to little up all that
makes horses mud seriously but its real
name is the man chenille tree and it
actually holds the Guinness world record
for the world's most dangerous tree the
menacing man chenille can be found in
the Caribbean Florida Mexico and all
across South America the tree is like an
angry pop boiling over with hatred and
childhood issues life can be tough as a
young sapling you know each part of the
tree wants to kill you in a different
organizing way the fruits it grows look
like apples smell like apples and even
taste like apples put her nuts apples
take a bite into a mansion kneel fruit
and you'll be like this is all right it
tastes like apple pie well then you'll
be hit with an intense peppery heat that
will quickly search for out your entire
body causing intense pain and severe
burning for hours your internal organs
will start to bleed your throat will
close up restricting your breathing and
then death will soon follow
geez that escalated from sweet to savory
pretty fast but here's the worst part
the fruits are the least toxic part of
the manchin eel tree there's a lot more
waste as twine eat whit wants to turn
you into driftwood the trees main source
of poison is from its deadly Sun its
branches constantly use out a sticky
white substance if just a drop of this
touches your skin it will burn right
through it like acid causing blisters
and agonizing pain if the SAP gets in
your eyes it can cause permanent
blindness and just like every other part
of this sadistic tree if you inhale it
or if the SAP ends of your bloodstream
it will kill you the Aboriginal people
of the Caribbean used a tree to their
advantage they used to SAP of the
mansion eel to make poison arrows which
were extremely effective famous Spanish
conquest adorn Juan Ponce de Leon was
actually killed by a narrow poisoned
with Munchen
Ilse during his final voyage to Florida
to establish a settlement in a battle
with the native-american Colusa people
he took a mansion ale poisoned arrow to
the knee well it was his fight actually
he escaped the battle but died soon
afterwards from the poison but you don't
even need to touch the man to kneel tree
to suffer its deadly consequences when
it rains the SAP is washed off the
leaves and branches and is dispersed all
around the tree via rainwater therefore
if you stand underneath of Mantinea tree
whilst it's raining your entire body
will quickly burn up and perish like
every talent show winners career and
you'll be left with blisters burns and
scars all over many beach-going tourists
have suffered horrific injuries while
seeking cover from the rain underneath
aman Tennille tree unbeknownst to its
dangers also if you burn the bark of the
Mantinea tree the smoke that is produced
is so toxic that it will permanently
blind anyone standing nearby
in fact this angry wooden booger is so
toxic that simply standing near it for a
prolonged period of time can cause
serious injuries and possibly death by
asphyxiation as your throat closes up
caused by just breathing in the trees
toxic scent something or someone has
seriously ticked off this psychopathic
tree it's as if you came onto its patch
on Christmas Day and slapped it silly
with its own suppling babies it was you
wasn't it shame on you you dirty tree
slapper thanks for watching if you think
making a murderer was shocking you ain't
seen nothing yet
it's estimated that every year in Japan
hundreds of people are wrongfully
convicted for crimes they didn't commit
there are hidden oil wells all over Los
Angeles these secret oil wells are
hidden right in plain sight some are
next to schools and shopping malls